[Music]
ancients learned genteel remainer
capital with 70% of Cambridge voters
electing to remain in the referendum if
the Lib Dems can re-emerge anywhere it
must surely be in this city of spires
and yet even in Cambridge the Lib Dems
at risk of growing against the tide is a
real slave driver that one in front of
me I'll be brutally on this right did I
get the place in the squad repeat
starting on novice squad novice love it
Oh God the people voted for what they
voted for I don't think you can
backtrack I think that for me actually
the ideal outcome from this election
will be a hung parliament I've convinced
myself that we're not going to leave at
a hung parliament to me makes that seem
more likely and without jeremy corbyn's
for sure I mean I could swim as a
potential prime minister I'm not
supposed to go so more so than six
months ago
imprudent oh yeah he sleeps well he
comes across swelling oh yeah it's true
tonight Jeremy Corbyn and labour
received much criticism in the wake of
the referendum for not taking a clear
position for exit but maybe for a party
which has voters on both sides
that's what to treat come on room you
think we'll get on Team Sky what I'm
really struck by in Cambridge talking to
voters is how many really remainer
people are very comfortable voting for
Jeremy Corbyn and labour and then I go
to leave constituencies and labour
voters they're also very comfortable
voting for Jeremy Corbyn they think that
we're going to leave bogeyed against
I'll here I was telling you exactly
we've got even found a voter who exactly
supporters anyone I was saying this is
perfect Oh Pete is the camera shovel I
think she's gonna do the brexit
grexit right and that's the best we can
do and yeah support Jeremy Corbyn is one
well I'm really bored lying with me
thank you very much mother cheers Cheers
Tim Farren's lib dems by contrast
couldn't have been clearer
they've bet the house on brexit but
according to Professor David Runciman
and his co-hosts at the university's
talking politics podcast it hasn't
worked the Ferren campaign I think has
been a disaster actually I mean I think
just if anyone has got this one wrong
it's him think this is a parochial
election Labour's success in this
campaign no question has been to make it
a bread and butter domestic welfare
election and I'm amazed I mean I
wouldn't have you been doing well is a
surprise but that's not as much of a
surprise if you've said six weeks ago
the big issues of contemporary politics
would not be getting a look in because
this would feel like a traditional
British election between a Left Party
and a right party on questions of tax on
welfare when I'm to the new posters they
say you campaign in poetry and govern in
prose well on brexit Jeremy Corbyn has
contained in blank verse he hasn't
filled in the gaps and so has helped
stitch he's fractured base together
Tim Farren's clarity on the other hand
looks likely to cost his party it's not
Cambridge than they're recovering beyond
this city's walls Louis Goodall scan use
Cambridge
[Music]